heute ist mal wieder eine menge passiert
und zwar habe ich ein neues video auf
einem zweig kanal hochgeladen ich habe
einen kindheits foto finsteren gepasst
und ich hab ne neue podcast folge
veröffentlicht und jetzt schon im sommer
bay fans an und zwar beispielsweise hier
eine person die sachen verkauft für vier
euro in einer aldi tüte und was ist da
genau drin bruder das jetzt aus stark
und zwar verkauft hat jemand dieses
fahrrad ging es wird auf jeden fall
lastenfahrrad transport fahrrad
einkaufswagen fahrrad getauft und es
kostet einfach nur 1490 euro
ich hätte gerne drei davon die verkauft
jemand einen philips fernseher und ein
interessent fragt alu ich kommen
verwundert fragezeichen fragezeichen der
verkäufer antwortete daraufhin sorry das
ist mir viel zu wenig der fernseher in
einem sehr guten zustand da musst du
schon mehr bieten okay okay was ist
deine tiefpunkt als meine frau mich
verlassen und die kinder mitgenommen hat
okay
das ist der nächste die bfl und zwar
sehe schon dass das ihr das foto ist man
weiß noch nicht genau was hier gerade
abgeht
im titel steht allerdings fließen legen
für zehn euro verhandelbar aus
neubrandenburg und der beschreibung
steht ich mache das hobby mäßig bruder
ich würde eher was anderes empfehlen uns
war sprachen lernen beim nächstenliebe
fehlt hier verkauft jemand eine
guardians of the galaxy brille er
schreibt allerdings in die
produktbeschreibung sonderedition
gardinen of the galaxy
hallo ich biete ihnen diese neuwertige
gardinen of the galaxy 2 3 d brille an
bruder es heißt guardian und nicht
gardine hier verkauft jemand eine kleine
figur wäre ich glaube allerdings dass er
leider nicht genau weiß was es überhaupt
für eine figur ist und zwar schreibt er
den titel des angebots pikachu älterer
bruder was ist ein älterer pikachu und
du hast picacho auch komplett falsch
geschrieben bei diesem nächstenliebe
verkauft wie man ein aquarium aquarium
und fische und zubehör zu verkaufen mit
f das ganze verkaufte auf jeden fall für
600 euro in harburg und unten in die
beschreibung schreibt ja auch noch mal
bei interesse melden alle fische sind
handzahm hat und bei diesem ebay
verkauft seine person seine socken und
ein potenzieller käufer fragt den hai
ist es schon gewaschen hye ja natürlich
schade
vielen dank damit menschen sind sämtlich
abstoßen ihr verkauft jemand das spiel
uncharted auf ebay und ein interessent
fragt uncharted wie vielen daraufhin
antwortet der verkäufer hallo grußformel
höfliche anrede mit anschließender frage
abschiedsgruß einfach die oben
aufgezählten bausteine in ganzen sätzen
verwenden dann klappt's vielleicht auch
mit einer antwort nur mut und nicht
selbst aufgeben grüße gebe auf habe kein
interesse mehr ich kann beide seiten
verstehen
irgendwo willmann höflichkeit mit drin
haben auf der anderen seite bruder du
willst einfach nur dann spiel los werden
lassen das doch kaufen
hier verkauft als nächstes jemand nudeln
bzw nudeln feldherr und schlecht zähne
hat leicht kochen in fünf minten mit
gesang
sie hätten zusammen essen yummy yummy
hadschi noch salat wilken mit sah ja
passt da kommt zu chinesisches bruder du
brauchst viel mehr als nur ein
deutschkurs hier verkauft jemand ein
monopoly-spiel schreibt in den titel
spiel monopoly für 10 euro und in die
beschreibung monopoly fast umgebracht
das könnte auch von mir kommen und das
hier ist der nächste ebay wo jemand
seine toiletten dekoration verkauft
ich weiß nicht wie viel langeweile du
hast bruder aber viel erfolg weiterhin
mit einer alufolie und kunst und beim
nächsten ebay fällig sagt jemand ich es
ist für geld hallo an alle liebhaber der
süßen versuchungen ich esse gegen
bezahlung sämtliche süßspeisen der
stelle davon eine fotodokumentation
meiner liebsten süßspeise sind kuchen
sahne schokolade flut lungs cupcakes und
eis ich bin jung nicht übergewichtig und
esse gerne und viel macht mir gerne ein
angebot wir werden uns sicher einig okay
okay er hat jemand eine wohnung zu
vermieten und zwar die untere etage für
eine kaltmiete von 800 euro und das hier
ist das foto ich frage mich einfach
bruder hast du da hast du dich von der
decke hängen lassen und so das foto
gemacht und kommen wir nun als nächstes
mal wieder zu einem reim und zwar rosen
sind rote nachgucken packe ich meine
taschen treffe meine freunde und rufe
hallo ihr vier flaschen
[Musik]
ich habe allerdings noch einen weiteren
raum rausgesucht und zwar ich brauche
einen job was ich backe ist nicht lecker
ich versuche ein firma praktikum becker
do
das jetzt nicht so stark vor allem in
der rechtschreibung sehe ich da
definitiv defizite was 40 was sagt price
sorry ist schon weg wohl wieder will es
du fragezeichen gibt mk ich habe es
nicht mehr
bruder gib ihm doch das produkt ist doch
egal ob du schon verkauft hast er fragt
auch so und hier verkauft hier mit einem
samsung smart tvs 65 zoll 4k und ein
interessent schreibt ihm ich kann dir 70
euro dafür geben sofort habe es als war
finde ich eine unverschämtheit das ist
gerade mal ein zehntel des preises und
ich habe keine vb angegeben ich habe
aber nicht mehr
ich bin ganz ehrlich ich habe gerade ein
bußgeldverfahren am arsch wegen auto und
echt kein geld für ein tv ich habe auch
nichts zu verschenken wenn du kein geld
für einen fernseher hast kannst du doch
keinen kaufen was bist du für ein ja
nicht wieder ganz klar auf der seite des
interessenten also wenn er kein geld hat
dann schenke ihm doch einfach da in die
smart tvs 5000 warum 4000 zahlenden
produktes ist ein fernsehmann das hier
ist der nächste ebay versteht schon
jemand verkauft hier seinen papagei in
die beschreibung schreibt er allerdings
papagei vogel für 70 euro
verhandlungsbasis
ja wer hätte nicht gern so ein papagei
und mache mich auch schon direkt weiter
mit einem kleinen teile magazin in blau
und zwar bekommt hat jemand die
nachricht chris gott ich habe interesse
auf die kleinteile fache gestell bitte
schicken sie mir telefonanrufe ich
zurück danke chris gott
grüß gott frau
was ist der nächste die bfl seht ihr
schon da verkauft jemand verschiedene
gewürze behälter er schreibt allerdings
in den titel geführt
erstellt
[Musik]
da
ich meine wer kennt sie nicht die
klassischen gefühls behälter und bei
diese liebe schreibt ein interessent hey
zehn euro inklusive versand liebe grüße
daraufhin antwortet der verkäufer hey 15
euro inklusive versand liebe grüße
sieben euro inklusive versand liebe
grüße ich schenke dir einfach das ist
eine super verhandlungsführung die ihr
gerade stattgefunden hat und bei diesem
nächsten iwf sehen wir wieder eine
verhandlung des schreibt der
interessenten was ist denn ihre
preisvorstellungen schickt dazu noch
seine telefonnummer und der verkäufer
antwortet guten morgen 350 euro
verhandlungs basis liebe grüße daraufhin
antwortet dann der interessent 9
was hätten sie denn gerne für den roller
bruder hat jedoch hat das hier ist der
nächste der kleinanzeigen fällt und man
sieht wie schon das ist eine
wunderschöne schaukel die hier verkauft
wird
allerdings schreibt er in den titel
hollywoodschaukel bruder ich würde dir
eine reise nach amerika sponsoren so
dass du dir in los angeles mal dass
hollywood logo anschauen kannst und dann
kannst du ja das ist aber denken eine
hollywoodschaukel beschreibungen
ich habe übrigens
ich habe keine ahnung was ich gerade
sein
will
container zerstört bei meinem kopf gut
mal einen fehler machen allerdings trägt
weiterhin mit dem nächstenliebe feld und
zwar verkauft jemand einen louis vitton
supreme pullover und ein interessent
fragt ihn ist das für für hunde weil du
schreibst ja vb in klammern vierbeiner
danke yamaha nein der pullover ist für
menschen gedacht aber warum vw ich habe
extra bei google geschaut und da stand
vierbeiner oder
vw steht für vogel beine du vollidiot
und bei diesem ebay verkauft mal wieder
jemand seinen schrank gegen die haben
wir in jeder folgenden verdammten
schrank dabei auf jeden fall verkaufte
jemand aus berlin-pankow diesen schrank
und schreibt und in die beschreibung
schöner sehr großer weißer
kleiderschrank maßen sind etwas
schwierig zu berechnen da ich nur ein
geodreieck ab
hatten wir nicht alle personen die dann
die maße in jägermeister flaschen
angegeben hatte konnte nun allerdings
auch schon zum vorletzten liebefeld für
die heutige und versucht dort jemand ein
iphone und ein typ mit einem iphone
schreibt ihm hallo ich biete ein
technisch voll funktionsfähiges handy an
es handelt sich hier um ein ei phone 7
mit 128 gb interesse schauen sie sich
doch einfach mein angebot an mit
freundlichen grüßen voll funktionsfähig
aber tat steht nicht und dann noch über
300 euro für den schrott schill mal es
gibt leute die sind dumm und kaufen so
was okay ich will endlich der letzte
weynfeldt für die heutige episode und
zwar verkauft jemand ein teachers 11
complete hin die buch und interessant
schreibt ihm haben sie das buch gelesen
hallo ja aber nicht komplett war das
buch hilfreich um was hin die zu
beibringen wieso interessieren sie sich
für hin die ja schon habe es für einen
kurs an der uni gekauft dann musste sie
bestimmt in indisches liebes wiederhören
frisch verliebt gefühl so was in indien
love songs gibt es nirgendwo auf der
welt dann steckt da noch ein youtube
link versuchen sie das einmal man
braucht das wörther nicht zu verstehen
nur gefühle fühlen wollen sie das buch
jetzt kaufen
nein ich suche ein deutscher frau war
nie in deutschland alles
egal
alles klar
stellt euch das heutige jetzt allerdings
auch beenden meine lieben freunde wenn
euch die heutige episode ebay fans mit
mir der flasche gefallen hat das gern
einen daumen hoch unter dem video hier
da schreibt mir gerne in die kommentare
ob ihr schon mal in indien watt wird
mich absolut gar nicht interessieren
allerdings befinden wir uns jetzt auch
im auto und hier oben ist ein smiley
eingeblendet wenn ihr noch kein abonnent
von meinem kanalseite ist es halt blöd
aber ihr könnt euch cooler machen indem
wir darauf klickt das ist kostenlos und
verpasst keine videos mehr und hier ist
ein video verlinkt von meinem zweikanal
was ich dort hochgeladen habe und zwar
habe ich einen typischen quarantäne tag
gefilmt und geblockt also schaut euch
das an